[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand gîte et des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres du Journal des mères menacées et
en colère face à la multiplication des
agressions les élus se sentent
abandonnés par l'État nous expliquera la
rédaction de lmtvart dès le début de ce
JT récolter des déchets à cheval la
nouvelle chaîne locale francilienne 20
minutes TV nous fera découvrir cette
initiative déployée en pleine zone
urbaine une idée vous le verrez bonne
pour l'environnement et plébisciter par
les habitants elle est le témoin d'une
époque disparue Françoise Dorigny
dévoile les souvenirs de sa vie dans un
ouvrage poignant entre Seconde Guerre
mondiale et mondanité parisienne
Christophe Rigaud l'a rencontré chez
elle et puis en fin de journal la
rédaction de Canal 32 nous dévoilera les
coulisses d'un événement un peu
particulier la course de caisse à oignon
de Chavanges un cocktail vous le verrez
de vitesse et de bonne humeur
voilà des agressions qui se multiplient
et une écharpe tricolore qui n'inspire
plus forcément le respect les maires de
France se sentent de plus en plus
délaissées apporter d'engueulades ils
sont aussi souvent victimes de
comportements violents exemple près du
Mans ou le maire de la petite commune de
spray a subi deux agressions à l'espace
de quelques années Jean-Yves Avignon se
dit aujourd'hui dépassé par la violence
de certains de ses concitoyens un sujet
d'Enzo Maubert pour elle MTV Sartre
c'est un endroit que le maire de Spa
n'arrive pas à oublier juste devant la
salle municipale c'est ici qu'il s'est
fait agresser le 14 juillet 2022 juste
après la fin des festivités la buvette
était fermée et là un groupe de 4 qui de
4 personnes qui est arrivé sans des prix
à un jeune de la commune
les agents de sécurité que nous avions
retenu sur cette soirée sont intervenus
se sont fait frapper par la personne en
question alors qu'ils essayaient de
défendre le jeûne et moi quand j'ai vu
que ça s'apprenait certaines ampleur je
suis intervenu en disant vous arrêtez je
suis le maire de la commune vous arrêtez
la personne est venue vers moi et m'a
gifler depuis le début de son mandat en
2014 c'est la deuxième agression dont
est victime l'élu ils savoure
aujourd'hui un puissant on nous dit
qu'on est OPJ officier de police
judiciaire on a l'impression qu'on n'a
pas de pouvoir applique les gens ils
nous respectent pas ces agresseurs sont
convoqués devant le tribunal en janvier
2024 un délai trop long selon le maire
qui craint des représailles on peut
retrouver mon domicile on peut voilà ce
qui s'est passé à Saint-Brévin on tend
le dos un certain nombre de mères à se
dire ben oui comment nous agresseurs ne
vont pas revenir tu en as besoin ou la
justice les convaincre très tard le 24
mai dernier les maires en appelé
justement à l'État face à ces agressions
verbales et physiques qui selon eux se
multiplient depuis la crise sanitaire je
sens à l'accueil aussi de la mairie
l'agressivité des personnes quand elles
ont des exigences et que ça n'aboutit
pas dans leur sens on a ce genre de
démarche qui fait que le contact est
quand même dur le 14 juillet prochain
Jean-Yves Avignon sera bien avec ses
administrés pour la fête nationale mais
cette fois-ci la municipalité a engagé
des maîtres chiens une solution
regrettée par le maire mais qui juge
essentiel pour éviter tout débordement
voilà et pour renforcer la sécurité de
chacun nombre d'élus ont désormais
recours à la vidéo surveillance un moyen
indispensable pour certains un coup trop
élevé pour d'autres l'installation de
caméra fait bien souvent polémique dans
la loi le projet d'un maire qui souhaite
implanter quatre caméras devra être
soumis à consultation citoyenne les
explications de Nathan Vacher pour TLS
regardez
[Musique]
stéphanoise avec de plus en plus de
faits délictueux un cambriolage une
agression à la sortie d'un restaurant un
collectif s'est créé contre l'arrivée de
ce système de vidéo surveillance
collectif qui a même déposé une pétition
que plus de 100 habitants a pour le
moment signé ce qui oblige le conseil
municipal à le traiter à Londres du jour
en vue d'une possible
citoyenne le collectif quant à lui
propose des solutions alternatives c'est
de dire
consacrer l'argent qui est prévu à la
prévention pour les ados parce que notre
problème il est plutôt au niveau des
ados ici on la petite enfance et les
personnes âgées sont parfaitement pris
en charge mais au niveau des ados et
comme ça change tout le temps mais
tous les trois quatre ans c'est une
nouvelle génération à l'unanimité les
élus ont voté pour la consultation
citoyenne qui devrait avoir lieu le 1er
octobre prochain pour connaître la vie
des plans fuyards sur l'arrivée de ces
vidéos surveillance
accédez facilement au monde médical
voilà l'une des principales
problématiques à la campagne manque de
médecins et vieillissement de la
population l'équation paraît impossible
à résoudre et si la solution se trouvait
dans la box medicale à container
transformé en un cabinet mobile de
téléconsultation une invention venue du
gars que nous fait découvrir Olivier
Michel pour via Occitanie
elle s'appelle la box medicale tient
dans un container s'apparente au cabinet
de téléconsultation installée dans
certaines pharmacies mais leurs
diffèrent mobiles elle peut être
implantée n'importe où et offre plus
d'intimité l'idée nous est venue pendant
le covid en s'est rendu compte qu'on
avait une grosse problématique de désert
médicaux en France et un moment donné
des solutions qui étaient proposées ne
nous paraissaient pas à satisfaisante en
termes de logistique la télémédecine
existait mais pour nous elle n'était pas
dans un écrin adapté donc il nous
fallait un endroit qui soit dédié et qui
soit autonome que l'on puisse y accéder
tout le temps le cabinet de télé
consultation est tout y est et permet de
rentrer en contact avec un médecin
généraliste voire un spécialiste
dermatologue ORL ou pneumologue alors
ici la bande dessinée de 6 objets
médicaux connectés ils ont tous la
particularité d'être pilotés à distance
par le médecin à l'issue de la
téléconsultation le médecin imprime
l'ordonnance
une démonstration parlante pour les
mères qui font face à la désertification
médicale il y a certains atouts parce
que aujourd'hui je suis sur un
territoire rural touristique et rural on
est 725 l'hiver et on passe sur les
coups de 6000 l'été et malheureusement
on peut mettre ça sur la commune et aux
alentours donc c'est vrai que l'avoir
sur la commune ce serait quand même un
plus coût global de la boxe médical
68000 euros selon une étude des
entreprises du secteur un patient sur
quatre qui téléconsultent vit dans un
désert médical d'été des consultations
qui participent aussi au désengorgement
des urgences
voilà santé encore dans ce journal avec
cette fois-ci la lutte contre les
addictions tabac alcool ou encore jeux
de hasard en Martinique la
sensibilisation et la protection des
mineurs se fait grâce à une campagne de
prévention pensée et réalisée par des
collégiens un moyen de mieux concerner
le public visé explication et image
recueillies par Jean-Marc quarteron pour
via à TV sur place
nous les enfants c'est encore plus grave
parce que on grandit avec avec des par
exemple si on arrête de fumer enfant il
y aura quand même des restes de
cigarette on va dire dans notre dans nos
poumons nous avons
dans notre établissement donc déjà
rencontré certaines difficultés par
rapport à la consommation donc d'alcool
et aussi de stupéfiants et donc nous
voulons participer vraiment à
l'éducation et à la sensibilisation de
nos jeunes et à ce qu'ils deviennent des
adultes responsables claude malurey
était l'invité ce jeudi matin de
l'émission Face au territoire sur TV5
Monde l'ancien ministre est désormais
sénateur c'est notamment exprimé sur
l'utilisation du réseau social TikTok
qui fait polémique alors qu'une
commission d'enquête poursuit
actuellement ses travaux à ce sujet
regardez cet extrait
et l'application qui prend le plus de
permis ce qu'on appelle des permissions
sur votre téléphone 44 permissions et
quand on y permission il y en a qui
ouvre lequel ils ne demandent pas la
permission c'est ce qu'on appelle de
l'octaoût et pas de l'optine donc c'est
pas si vous adhérez à l'application oui
bien sûr qu'ils en sert d'abord ils s'en
servent pour des raisons normales pour
la peau cibler la publicité etc et puis
il y a des tas de permission quand on
les regarde qui ne servent à rien pour
l'application donc vous avez un nombre
de permissions extrêmement important
deuxièmement la fuite de données en
Chine est avérée elle a été prouvée
notamment aux États-Unis étiquela qui a
fini par être obligé de le reconnaître
les Américains ou les Anglais
interdisent à leur fonctionnaires d'État
d'utiliser Tik Tok sur leur téléphone on
fait la même chose depuis trois mois
face au territoire avec Claude malurey
et ta voix ou revoir sur les sites
internet de TV5 Monde et des partenaires
de l'émission Ouest-France Nice-Matin 20
minutes la montagne le magazine Le Point
est bien sûr France Antilles tout à fait
autre chose mieux informé et
sensibiliser le public aux risques
d'incendie voilà les objectifs de la
météo des forêts proposés depuis le
début du mois par Météo France et
élaborer grâce aux prévisions
météorologiques et l'état de sécheresse
de chaque département celle-ci permet
d'établir une carte liée au danger
d'incendie précision recueillies à
Toulouse par Manon van Overbeke pour la
Dépêche du Midi
on dispose déjà à Météo France de calcul
de d'analyse et de prévisions des
conditions feu météorologiques à
résolution kilométrique sur l'ensemble
du territoire de la France et ce jusqu'à
4 jours d'échange donc c'est sans des
calculs assez importants et assez
volumineux pour cela on les fait on les
réalise deux fois par jour sur notre
supercalculateur et c'est l'ensemble de
ces informations que l'on a cherché à
valoriser en les agrégeant à l'échelle
départementale pour produire ce
dispositif de la carte de météo déforie
voilà et sachez que ces informations
concernant les risques d'incendie sont
consultables sur le site
météo-france.com bien sûr et
l'application mobile de Météo France
traverser la Méditerranée pour rejoindre
la Corse vous serez nombreux à emprunter
cet itinéraire cet été et à côté des
traditionnelles traversées en ferry une
nouvelle offre se développe pour se
rendre sur l'île de Beauté le voilier
une coopérative propose depuis l'été
2022 une liaison quotidienne entre
Saint-Raphaël et Calvi une option avant
tout écologique vous allez le voir les
précisions avec ce reportage de Loïc Le
Prince pour télépaser sur place
se rendre en Corse oui mais comment
depuis deux ans une coopérative propose
à des voyageurs de faire la traversée
envoyée aujourd'hui ce sont 7 passagers
qui ont choisi cette option cette
liaison existe depuis deux ans et